now 6 40 on a monday morning on a back
to school
monday monica good morning to you it's a
big day oh it really
is a big day i got to say a big shout
out to my son d'artagnan he's going to
10th grade
i know you first day of high school you
brought him here as well
before before school that's a long day
man it is he's good he's only 15. are
you kidding he's got energy to spare
and welcome back to you by the way mr
vacation man
jet setting tried to yeah jet setted
train said it and now i'm set-setted
all right well john as you know
everybody else wake up wake up you
sleepy heads because it's the first day
of school
ccsd back in class and with the pandemic
still going on yeah i know it sucks but
things are going to get a little better
they're going to be a little different
so joining me now to talk about how
parents and
teachers can help their kiddos acclimate
to the quote new normal at school
is john edsel he is the executive
director of boys town nevada
john thank you so much for being here
how are you
good morning monica great i'm doing
really well it is it is a busy busy
morning with yeah
i bet okay so john before we get into it
tell everybody about boys town nevada
and what you guys do over there
definitely so boys
nevada is a local non-profit that has
been in the valley for 30 years now
opened our doors back in 1991 we do a
wide variety of services
all related to kids and families
including some work with ccsd
uh but we've also got a behavioral
health clinic with three full-time child
psychologists to work with nothing but
kids
uh we also do a lot of work where we go
into families homes yeah where we work
directly with them
around their kitchen tables or dining
rooms or wherever it is that they're
most comfortable working
very cool okay so let's get into it
because i'm going to put it out there
john and his wife are parents to
three teenagers god bless you for that
share with our viewers john how you all
have
been able you know to manage the kiddos
and tackle all the challenges that have
come
with the pandemic because with teenagers
that's like a rite of passage for kids
so it can be really challenging i have a
15 year old now
so i'm seeing it as well yeah and we
certainly
we share that in common i've got an 18
16 and 15 year old
just graduated this past spring and
right now a junior and a sophomore that
literally just walked out my door
uh about 30 seconds ago back to their
first day of school
so first of all i'd really just like to
make sure we're all really appreciating
the
teachers the administrators the
paraprofessionals the bus drivers all
the support staff
who are so excited to get the kids back
into school
today uh that is a phenomenal
achievement and really
a fantastic uh demonstration of their
resilience over the past
16 or 18 months so great to have kids
going back but i tell you
having three teenagers certainly a
challenge right now because
as i learned more than anything else
over the last you know 18 months is that
each one of my kids were a little bit
different and how they responded to
responded to that distance learning into
the pandemic
and i cannot emphasize that enough with
parents
their ability to demonstrate that
flexibility
have that communication um with their
kids because
each one is going to be a little bit
different in in how they've responded to
it
right and john let me jump in here
because i want to put this up on the
screen for parents
not only have i heard you say this but
i've seen this on social
media as well over the last couple days
parents need
you know they're going to need a lot of
help and advice teachers as well when it
comes to
managing this new normal in school and
at home you have these very simple tips
they're very simple but they're very
helpful and i think because of
everything that's going on as parents
we tend to forget so let's talk about
those the first one is communication
yeah communication monica it is so
important
for parents to be communicating with
their kids about what
is going on in their world right now
when it comes to education
and we've got to do a good job of
listening to what their perception
is of what's happening and i think
oftentimes as
parents we try to sort of project out
what we think is going on
without truly listening to their
perspective
and to their perception because that is
their reality
and is going to be different than ours
because raise your hand if you've been
through a
pandemic before right this is different
we can't say hey we did this when when
we were teenagers like we could
you know two years ago and say yep i've
gone through that you know we can't
in this you know instant so absolutely
it's really important that we're
listening to our kids
yeah okay number two you say flexibility
and i think as parents this is the one
we have a hard time with because
i grew up in a house so i don't know
about you it's do as i say not as i do
but this is a whole different day and
age you have to be flexible
especially with the pandemic yeah
absolutely
and we just heard dr jarrah talk about
it as well as we've got to be flexible
uh with our kids we've got to be willing
to give them a little bit of a break as
well
yeah and again it goes back to
communication we've got to be willing to
listen to what
they've got going on and understanding
that it might be a little bit more
difficult
um and so when we're able to to give our
kids a little bit more of a break
around things it's going to help them be
more successful
uh and i i agree growing up in a house
somewhat similar to that
um you know we've got to think outside
the box just a little bit
and and give our kids a little bit more
flexibility as to
what they're seeing and what's going to
help them be successful
all right and i'm almost out of time
here excuse me john the last one is
routine slash schedule
i think this might be the most important
because i
i know with even uh special needs kids
routine
and scheduling is very important so that
you don't disrupt their comfort level
absolutely uh we've got to work with our
kids to create that routine you got me
you need to make realistic expectations
as to what can be done whether that's a
specific place that you're doing
homework whether you've got a whiteboard
you know posted up saying you know wake
up time is this breakfast time is this
we leave for the school bus or we leave
to drive to school at this time
but creating that schedule with your kid
and again being willing to be flexible
to make those changes to that schedule
um based on after the first couple weeks
okay this is too early to get up or
we're not able to do that
and the same thing when kids get home do
they have a place that they can do
homework are you
checking on that homework are you
working with them you know through the
infinite campus app
to make sure that that homework is
getting done you know so we get those
notifications
um all the time but creating that
expectation
with your student or students is really
important it's very important okay so
john i'm out of time here
we know that with the pandemic a lot of
kids have gone through anxiety okay
and so they're probably going to be
cases where teachers deal with crisis in
the classroom
parents deal with crisis at home how can
someone get in touch with you if they
need immediate help
to get your advice and or your services
yeah they can give us a call at
702-642-7070
or they can send us an email at info
hope
that boystown.org uh and we've always
got somebody available
uh speaking english and spanish to pick
up the phone and talk with them about
our services talk with them about
getting in touch with one of our
psychologists in order to best help them
in whatever needs that they may have
all right wonderful well hey again god
bless you with your three teenagers and
i'm getting mine off to school
this morning too high school man i'm
freaking out
anyway john we appreciate you thank you
so much and for everything you guys do
over there boys town nevada
thank you monica all right hey folks and
don't forget to catch my moj show
facebook live weeknights
at 7 pm